[Music]
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 51
all right welcome to hannity busy news
night day 51 our fellow americans that's
right abandoned thousands of americans
the green card holders eligible to be in
this country abandoned afghan allies
tens of thousands of them abandoned
their families abandoned behind enemy
lines thanks to joe biden and tonight it
is more clear than ever joe biden his
radical socialist friends are completely
totally incompetent and clueless and
have no desire to help bail out our
fellow americans they caused this this
was entirely preventable and they're not
lifting a finger to help americans in
need everything they do causes an
unmitigated disaster look at the record
afghanistan the border covered 19. labor
day last year versus this year 300
increase look at the economy look at
inflation look at
eliminating energy independence that we
had achieved under the trump
administration for the first time in 75
years we're now all paying about a buck
50 more a gallon and joe's begging opec
to produce more energy by the way joe
you could ask texas and oklahoma and
north dakota and alaska they can
increase their production and guess what
we can be energy independent again you
can secure the border finish the wall
keep the remaining mexico policy that
problem will be solved too and by the
way you should go back and get our
fellow americans in afghanistan biden's
approval ratings at an all-time low and
this year at sporting events all across
the country jimmy kimmel pay attention
guess what they've been chanting the
following f joe biden in mass take a
look
[Applause]
byte administration is a train wreck
democrats are in a civil war and we you
the american people have no reason to be
happy over any of this and over the
weekend more chance look at talladega
speedway over the weekend take a look
just such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me
you can hear the chance from the crowd
let's go brandon
it's happening everywhere spontaneously
the media mob they're doing everything
possible to protect joe biden first it
was the candidate protection program now
it's the presidential protection program
a task by the way that's growing more
impossible by the hour now another
crisis for joe biden has insane spending
bills socialism bills they are now stuck
in limbo they cannot be passed at the
moment doesn't seem like any time in the
near future
majorities in the house the senate
democrats are unable to pass their own
trillion-dollar infrastructure bill as
well as their radical new green deal
socialist bill 3.5 trillion dollars
their bill back a better proposal that
raises taxes on all of us in spite of
their lying to hold up of course we have
a civil war standoff between liberal
democrats and then the more socialists
bordering on status communist democrats
on friday what many are calling a weird
hollow gesture that joe biden did
nothing he just limped over to the
capitol and encouraged his fellow
democrats to get along and to play nice
but here's the interesting part
according to a political reporter joe
actually attempted he was willing to
take questions from
other congressmen and senators in the
press
his staff again oh i'm going to get in
trouble no they get mad at me they're
going to yell at me if i take a question
i'm not allowed show you the president
it's almost as if joe biden isn't in
charge isn't it in other words his staff
knows he's a cognitive mess now we do
know for a fact that radical socialists
are ruling the democratic party with an
iron fist and per usual they are
definitely not playing nice this weekend
look at this in arizona one unhinged
group of activists including several
illegal immigrants stalking democratic
senator kristen simmoner cinema they
chased her
into a bathroom stall and stayed outside
the stall and kept filming
wow we need a buildback better plan
right now
we we're not going to absorb
we need solutions to build that better
plan need has the solutions that we need
i'm going to stand there and film while
she's going to the bathroom senator
cinema one of only two democrats
refusing to rubber stamp biden's insane
and it is insane we can't afford it
these policies will fail these are false
promises you will give up your freedom
it will result in more poverty like
every socialist utopia you know in the
past has done and by the way 3.5
trillion their eco socialist amnesty for
all spending bill and tonight she's
calling out democratic leadership for
their quote inexcusable deeply
disappointing actions
and senator sinema's colleague joe
manchin also refusing to sign off on
this monstrosity
and the liberal democrat from west
virginia will only commit to a mere 1.5
trillion dollar bill uh okay some level
of fiscal responsibility i guess i don't
think we should be spending a penny
especially after all the money we had to
spend as it relates to the worst
pandemic since 1917 and 18. even mansion
is confronted by activists on his
houseboat on the potomac but first you
might be wondering what does joe biden
think about his fellow democrats being
stalked and harassed by other democrats
you would think that maybe joe biden
would speak out right according to joe
it's just part of a process for those
that don't enjoy the secret service
protection that he enjoys take a look
joe manchin had people on kayaks show up
to his boat pl senator cinema last night
was chased into a restroom do you think
that those tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so uh it's it's part of
the process
this part of the process you won't stick
up for your fellow senators i guess then
it's all part of the process you getting
f joe biden all over every stadium
around the country getting followed into
a bathroom stall videotape while going
to the bathroom is that part of the
process you support joe
whatever happened to standing up for a
woman's right to privacy what about
showing up at someone's house and
shouting them down
where they live that's part of the
process joe
and what if someone came to your
basement during your midday nap joe it's
not appropriate it's wrong it's
unethical and you should have stuck up
for both mansion and cinema
mob rule is never part of the process
joe but that's right you wouldn't even
talk about the 534 riots in the summer
of 2020. democrats only want to talk
about january 6th they don't want to
talk about the riots that killed dozens
of americans
injured thousands of cops pelted with
bricks and rocks and bottles and molotov
cocktails and people dozens of people
killed thousands of cops injured
i'm joe biden he's been what he's been
his entire life a dishonest lifelong
swamp sewer
politician ingrained with always swamp
now true to form joe biden just can't
stop lying about the 3.5 trillion dollar
quote build back better bill it's all
bumper sticker and a slogan and a lie
you know he's someone that actually is
claiming and still claiming and people
on a staff are claiming that when you
spend 3.5 trillion dollars it will cost
you nothing
that's a lie even the washington post
accused biden of lying gave him a few
pinocchios for that one referring to his
lie as a dubious gimmick that's being
polite it's a lie hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else